si de esa cifra total de fallecidos 16
personas perdieron la vida aquí en el
estado de nueva york la mayoría porque
quedaron atrapadas en sus vehículos o en
sus casas y es que a pesar de que la
primera recomendación en estos casos es
que permanezcamos en nuestros hogares
esta vez muchos de ellos se convirtieron
en auténticas trampas mortales cuando
comenzaron las fuertes lluvias a medida
que avanza el día podría subir esa cifra
total de fallecidos conforme avanzan las
labores de rescate porque todavía hay
gente desaparecida unas labores que no
están siendo nada fáciles porque todavía
hay cientos de carreteras completamente
anegadas por el agua y las que no lo
están han quedado bloqueadas porque
mucha gente abandonó sus vehículos
tratando de salvar su vida además la
comunicación se hace muy complicada más
de 150 mil personas se han quedado sin
suministro eléctrico también ha ocurrido
eso en luisiana donde está visitando el
presidente yobái de la zona para evaluar
los daños causados por esta tormenta
tropical lo hacía justo después de
aprobar el estado de emergencia en nueva
york y en nueva yersey algo que permite
a estos estados ceder cuanto antes a la
ayuda federal porque los destrozos son
muchos y muy cuantiosos para que os
hagáis una idea solamente en pensilvania
y en nueva yersey tocaron tierra siete
tornados uno de ellos arrasó con 20
casas y este es el balance de lo que se
considera ya el quinto huracán más
dañino de la historia de eeuu